welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and baby yoda was a hungry hungry
fatso recently in the mandalorian this
season
going from an adorable moppet who
occasionally freaks us out by eating
frogs or choking out gina carano to
an insane space kobayashi gulping down
precious cargo in ice spider babies with
zero regard for the inevitable
nightmares he would leave us with i have
explored this egg gulping a bit in
recent videos
suggesting the child might just be super
hungry because he's in store for a
sudden growth spurt
given his species apparent s-shaped
aging curve or even that he might
hock back up one of these eggs if
something bad happens to all the others
since
i didn't see any chewing but i think
both of these explanations are just a
bit too simple
it was so simple just because the scene
with baby yoda and eggs was so
weird this is beyond hunger it's really
closer to
well what my hunger looks like for
cheesecake it's
spiritual soul defining and nope
i do not chew it i'm going to explain my
theory for where i think this
is going spoiler warning in case i'm
right or any of my cheesecake tangents
scare you
and uh yes i am wearing our custom this
is the way shirt from our official merch
store newrockstarsmerch.com
these are limited editions they're
running out fast so jump on these along
with our masks hoodies hi i'm eric bosch
shirts we got it all okay let's revisit
the moment baby yoda lays eyes on the
frog lady's eggs
what's the cargo it's her spawn she
needs her eggs fertilized by the equinox
or her line will end
she said her husband has settled on the
estuary moon of trask in the system of
the gas giant collide
[Music]
do you know the husband no i just met
her 10 minutes before you walked in
i thought you said you vouched for her
on your life and you can see the toddler
toddling right after him okay and then
let's jump ahead a few minutes later
where the child toddles back up to the
eggs smooshes his nose against the glass
and then
those eggs gravitate ever so slightly
toward him
and over this is ludwig gorinson's music
[Music]
yes this dreamy john williams-esque
music
framing this moment as one of the
innocent curiosity like e.t
waddling up into elliott's bedroom
gobbling up reese's pieces now to be
clear pelimoto specified that the frog
lady's eggs are
not fertilized fabiota ain't chowing
down on some unborn younglings he's
basically just eating eggs out of a
carton and weirding everyone out at a
trader joe's
given the fact that the show released a
figurine specifically with baby yoda and
the egg canister this relationship
must be important not just hunger not
just goofy shenanigans and not
carnivorous monstrosity
but familiarity a sense of home baby
yoda recognizes these eggs
he connects with them in a way that he
hasn't really connected with anything
else on the show so far but before i
continue thank you to
bessie's shoes for sponsoring this video
bessie makes these knit sneakers that
are 100
waterproof and weatherproof they are
super breathable with an antimicrobial
insole so your feet can smell good and
feel good
thus these shoes are super stretchy they
fit like a sock
and they only weigh 175 grams which is
lighter than an iphone and way lighter
than those clunky winter boots that
you're probably stomping around in
they're made with the space age dynamex
material so these are shoes you can wear
every day
in all kinds of weather they're also
super easy to clean with just a splash
of water
vessies are also vegan and sustainably
made with way less
waste than the industry standards
whether you're hiking exercising
or just running errands around town
besties will keep your feet warm and dry
and looking great
you know just doing some patio
[Music]
my shoe got a little wet but you know
what didn't get wet my
toes still bone dry thanks to these
besties and in the month of november
they've had this incredible black friday
offer where you can grab yourself a pair
for the rainy season while they still
have sizes and you can thank me later
check them out in the link below but if
you miss the black friday
itself sale you can still use my code
new rockstars to get
25 off your bessie shoes get on these
you're gonna love
to get them on you so when it comes to
baby yoda and these eggs perhaps the
most telling clues are
the basic pieces of information that
have been cryptically kept from us
like yeah we still do not know baby
yoda's name his species his origin he's
really just
the child but oddly we also don't know
the name or the race of the frog lady i
mean maybe you do by the time
chapter 11 has come out or some future
episode but not by this episode's taping
even in the official poster for her
character she is just called
frog lady that is not normal for star
wars folks pretty much every other time
we meet a new character we're given some
in-universe identifier
their name or their race mithral weak
way we almost never use a simple
qualifier using the earth fauna
nomenclature
frog lady where sounded like the kids
who call him dark vader
also pay close attention to what the
frog lady says about her past
these eggs are the last fruit of my life
my husband has risked his life to carve
out an existence for us
on the only planet that is hospitable to
our species
we fought too hard and suffered too much
to resign ourselves to the extinction of
our family
yeah we all kind of moved past this but
this is a huge detail the frog lady says
trask is the only planet romanian in the
galaxy that is hospitable for her
species
but that doesn't make sense presumably
she and her husband originated from some
other planet with an ecosystem
biologically sustainable for their kind
but one that is no longer hospitable
so she and her husband must be refugees
to trask
after their home planet was destroyed or
rendered inhospitable in some way i also
find it interesting that the show
decided to base her on an amphibious
egg-laying species native to swamps
because a little we know about yoda's
original conception
is that george lucas kind of based him
on a frog
in particular in 1997 he said that he
based yoda on fairy tale mythology
characters like a frog
or an eccentric old man on the side of
the road who seems insignificant but is
revealed to have a secret greater
significance
and that frog inspiration of course lent
itself to the setting of dagobah a swamp
planet though
not yoda's home world in truth this
setting was a refuge an exile after the
empire took over but
why choose a swamp if not something that
would be comfortable for
him huh i believe the destroyed home
world of the frog lady and baby yoda's
origin
are linked and that these two could
originate from
the same mystery planet that would
explain baby ota's seemingly natural
connection to these eggs of this species
why they respond to him like fish in a
tank wanting to give your hand a little
kiss
that's love there is something pure and
natural about baby yoda consuming these
things
almost as if his race could be a natural
predator to these things and this is
more like a homecoming meal or maybe
even like you know clownfish live within
a sea anemone
bees carrying pollen from a flower to
fertilize other plants
a kind of mutualistic symbiotic
relationship
where these eggs could naturally benefit
from the yoda species taking them in
as a stage of their life cycle or to
fortify or protect them
and we have to assume there is something
natural about baby yoda's origin because
despite some clues that he could be tied
to the cloning facilities of kamino
kuwill said
i don't think it was engineered i've
worked in the gene farms
this one looks evolved too ugly
and if we are trying to zero in on what
that mystery home planet could be
lots of planets in the star wars
universe have aquatic and swampy
ecosystems
dagobah naboo and many of these planets
have suffered ecological interference
and deforestation in the clone wars
colonialization by the empire other
conflicts we saw a bit of that on naboo
at the beginning phantom menace but back
in the first episode this season on the
mandalorian we might have gotten a major
clue
when mando and the child go to meet
gorkhoresh they pass a ton of
anti-imperial graffiti
baby yoda even looks over curiously to
take note of some of it
and he gives off a little expression at
the exact moment he passes
some orbish text that we translated to
alderaan now sure lots of folks across
the galaxy likely remain furious with
the empire for blowing up alderaan it's
a horrible war crime
and cara dune was actually revealed to
be from alderaan herself if you look at
alderaan it was known both for
mountainous
and aquatic terrain but as one planet
fully annihilated at this point in the
star wars timeline
it is at least a candidate for a planet
this refugee frog lady could be seeking
resettlement from
and uh based on babe yoda's powerful
food craving a possible origin for
this adorable question mark and yes we
actually did explore baby yoda's
possible swamp origins in last week's
episode of rogue theory you're
definitely going to want to check that
out and next week we're going to have a
deeper dive into the yoda species
biology and reproductive cycle in big
question
and there's going to be a special guest
on it it's going to be a real after dark
episode hold on to your butts
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification button follow me at ea boss
follow me rockstars see you next time
and
on to some cheesecake
[Music]
you